before we get to part two of my
interview with Natasha she'll about
casino design gambling addiction etc
which people yesterday really seemed to
like that interview I want to talk about
one more aspect of Donald Trump's
proposed tax reform we went into
significant detail about the tax reform
at the beginning of the show here's just
one other aspect of it a sort of legal
aspect just like Donald Trump's
embarrasing attempt to repeal Obamacare
uh Trump's tax plan could also quickly
fail in Congress most if not all
Republicans would love to pass Donald
Trump's tax plan it makes big tax cuts
it reduces the corporate tax rate by
more than 50 percent it has no way to
make up for lost revenue this is the
kind of plan that right-wingers sort of
live for but even though both houses of
Congress or majority Republican these
tax cut proposals from Trump are so
outrageous that they might actually
violate Senate rules this is not some
left-wing talking point that I'm
presenting to you this is according to a
staffer for Republican Congressman Paul
Ryan George calles is Paul Ryan's Senior
Tax Counsel he ridiculed the tax plan
saying it's a quote magic uniformed
unicorn rather because of how outrageous
it is take a listen to what he had to
say I want to a very very important
point here a plan of business tax cuts
that has no offsets to using some very
esoteric language it's not a thing
it's not a real thing and people can
come up with whatever plans they want
that is not not only can that not pass
Congress it cannot even begin to move
through Congress day one and there are
political reasons for that number one
members wouldn't vote for it but there
are also procedural statutory procedural
legal reasons why they that can't happen
what what the reconciliation rules say
they say that you cannot have a deficit
increase beyond the 10-year window
okay so here's what
talking about since Democrats won't be
voting for Donald Trump's tax plan
Republicans in theory have to abide by
the Senate's budget reconciliation rules
to prevent filibustering and passed the
resolution by a simple majority okay
under those rules written into federal
statute the new budget wouldn't be able
to increase the deficit for more than
ten years that's why the Bush tax cuts
were set to expire after ten years
Donald Trump's proposed tax cuts are so
drastic that they would affect the
deficit even after they expire so in
order to prevent it from adding to the
deficit beyond ten years you'd have to
expire it long before ten years in fact
the Joint Committee on taxation this is
just unbelievable says that Trump's
corporate tax cuts would need to expire
in less than three years to avoid
increasing the deficit for more than ten
years
that's how deficit exploding they are so
in order to pass Trump's tax plan the
Senate would have to make the corporate
tax cut and after about two and a half
years which basically makes it
meaningless it would end before Donald
Trump's first term even ends it's
possible that Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell might be able to figure
out some kind of maneuver on the Senate
floor
but according to this particular tax
lawyer that I quoted Trump's tax plan is
coming from such a Fantasyland that
there is actual federal law in place
meant to keep something like this from
being passed so what is Trump thinking
he either didn't know about the rule
very likely or he thinks some Democrats
might vote for the plan I don't think
that's too likely the most likely
scenario is as usual Trump is clueless
and he's fumbling around in the dark and
this could be the latest the next
shamefully hilariously failed proposal
we can hope and we'll be following it
this is a discussion happening on our
reddit discussion forum at david
pakman.com slash reddit today's program
is made possible in part by Gamefly
which is sort of like netflix for video
games they've got over 8,000 new and
classic games for xbox one Xbox
we sixty ps4 ps3 Wii and a bunch of
other platforms and you can also stream
games you don't even need a gaming
console or a computer because you can
stream games through your Amazon fire
stick or Roku box and then use your
mobile phone as the controller you can
play as many games as you want for one
monthly fee and if you find some games
you want to keep you can buy them for a
low used price never with due dates or
late fees and our audience can get a
30-day free trial at Gamefly offer.com
slash TDP s the games are shipped
directly to you with return envelopes
included no contracts and you can also
stream the games I think I mentioned
that you can also rent games through the
mobile app get a free 30 day trial for
david pakman show viewers and listeners
and support our show at Gamefly
offer.com forward slash TDP s